good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast and happy Friday Friday
gotta get down on Friday it is a
gorgeous Friday back in studio week one
of Jackie's return from maternity leave
and I am joined by a gorgeous co-host he
is host of the good guys podcast fellow
semi-glue tied user founder of Spritz
Society apple of my eye it's Ben Soffer
hey Ben software celeb how you doing I'm
doing wonderful thanks that's great how
are you I'm feeling like the Friday like
itch I'm like first of the weekend first
but you know I was unemployed all last
month let's talk about that what was it
like having me home just kind of like
doing nothing you weren't doing that I
know I lowkey was busy also like talk
into the microphone okay like nice and
close I mean I was I wasn't sure I was
comfortable in talking into the mic I'm
sorry just like move it closer to you
yeah yeah because it's like too close
it's never too close Okay
um you were busy you were busy like I
don't know if like you you talk about
this but like you're just like hitting
the gym every day I know like you're out
there doing these classes running uphill
are you running down Hills are you
threatened by my newfound just like
athleticism are you jealous no I'm
definitely annoyed by the Newfound
complaining that comes with your new
hobby in terms of what I don't feel like
I complain about anything no it's just
like constantly sore constantly tired
but like I guess you were sore and tired
before anyways so like now it's like at
least I'm like bettering myself you're
bettering yourself yeah um but I'm
incredibly proud of you thank you you uh
took the time off and really did
something with it I did something with
it uh and yeah so you're proud of me I
am proud of you well it's so great to
have you back so much has happened since
the last time you've been on the toes
when was the last time I was on the
toast I don't know I was on your podcast
during my maternity leave so if you guys
haven't listened to that it was actually
a fabulous episode and we talked a lot
about both of our Journeys were those
epic yes we did and it was a fabulous
episode so I feel like we actually don't
have that much catching up to do no we
really don't listen to the good guys the
episode with Claudia it really was
fantastic well I should catch up on the
other ones too great show if I might I
was gonna say here I'm gonna give you
100 seconds
go wild promote whatever you want to
promote three across the board across
the board three two one action first and
foremost Good Guys hosted by myself and
Josh Peck if you guys aren't listening
which I'm sure the majority of you
aren't Woody and nuts it's a fantastic
podcast we guess like Hilary Duff
Claudia ashrae John Stamos I mean it's
really an unbelievable podcast a little
A-list talent because Ben's co-host is
like an actually famous person not like
fake like us you know and then we have
solo episodes where me and Josh just
have unbelievable banter you're gonna
love it it's fantastic so go either
Watch the episodes all the episodes are
live on Josh Peck's YouTube or listen
wherever you get your podcasts next
Spritz Society you'll notice there's a
little box of pink lemonade here folks
coming soon bye by popular demand
everybody wanted this flavor back it
happens to be my favorite and we are
going to be re-releasing it so look out
for that next week go to spritzocity.com
and sign up for the notifications to be
notified when pink lemonade drops again
gorgeous you killed it yeah that's it I
think so
um good guys and Spirits thanks birds
and good guys good guys and Spirits yes
um wait I wanted to ask you one more
thing before you're going to dive into
the fast five stories with me today yes
we are oh but uh Ben and I have gone on
a journey you know we've been through a
few Journeys in these last few years we
have um we have started and completed
young Sheldon that was a big area for us
yes we are currently in our suits era we
are we're going to talk about suits but
last night we re-entered our The Nanny
era and let me just say I have no
interest in watching Suits anymore like
I'm obsessed with the nanny it's
literally I find myself cackling like it
didn't actually funny show what I think
is so cool about the nanny is that I
don't think we've ever watched it
together in our 11 years of being
together yeah yeah we both know every
single word to the theme song three two
one she was working at a bridal shopping
place in Queens Taylor boyfriend kicked
her out in one of those crushing scenes
what was she to do where
on me
for me who would have guessed that the
father described was just exactly what
the doctor prescribed now the father
finds out Cece and the kids are actually
smiling
everybody else
[Applause]
it's
bad I always thought it was such
wannabes that's the song they wrote
about you not that Alex excuse me so you
were saying you were saying I was just
saying like unbelievable show the fact
that we both just like loved it from
childhood and it comes back and it
stands the test of time it's like most
shows that you bring back you're like I
used to like this crap so true no
offense like that's how I feel about
Seinfeld okay that's like the hottest
dumbest take I've ever heard I just
didn't watch Seinfeld as a
seven-year-old no I just like I don't
think it's funny why'd you just like
bring in Seinfeld for no reason because
I think more people should talk about
how not funny it is it is it's just
literally not it is that said curb is
better but 100 but they're both like is
that even a question like people are
like curb versus Seinfeld like it's not
even a question for people who don't
watch curb for sure for sure like
another thing about the nanny that I
don't think I realized at the time
because when I watched it it was always
on it Nick at night 11 o'clock I would
watch it right before bed good night so
good
um and I when I was watching it I was
very much like a Jewish girl living you
know in a Jewish World going to Jewish
school Jewish camp like things being
Jewish were not out of the norm for me
but now like I'm an adult and I live in
the real world and the show is so Jewish
and it's so like proudly Jewish and it's
really an accurate reflection of like
Jewish culture especially like in New
York and queens and it's such a delight
to watch and an acceptance of said
Culture by a very waspy non-jewish
family yeah friends outfits are amazing
I feel like friends been in the news a
lot I feel like you're always talking
about friend on your podcast because
she's the leader of zag the SAG Union
and obviously you guys are abiding by
the SAG we're askers you know me yeah
right starring in lead roles I have to
respect Zach of course of course of
course so she's it's just nice to remind
ourselves like where she came from yeah
it's a fabulous show it's on Max I can't
recommend watching it enough absolute
Legends and then suits we've kind of
been in our suits era let's talk about
that suits is great literally could not
hold a candle to the nanny I agree just
that's just the the truth they're
different shows it's apples and oranges
they're totally different shows but like
one is so iconic and Suits is great but
it's no nanny it's no nanny and we're
also in like this part of suits in
season seven where things are just a
little bit crazy like Donna like spoiler
alert even though the show came out 10
years ago
Donna wanted to be like a partner at the
firm and it's like I respect women in
business but like you're not a lawyer uh
everything's just kind of being like
turned upside down and making no goddamn
sense and everyone is honestly being
dumb
whatever writer wrote In The Donna
becomes coo and stops being Harvey's
secretary when the only reason one one
of the only reasons people like the show
is that a dynamic between Harvey and
Donna this whole secretary lawyer like
there's like all this like sexual
innuendo this passion this fire they
know each other best and all of a sudden
they're like on the equal playing field
and then there's no longer lust and it's
like it's just such like a but here's
what I think and this is what I was
explaining to you it kind of made no
sense like her coming out of left field
not wanting to be a legal secretary
anymore and like wanting to be a partner
um and so I felt like I don't know yet
because I don't know how the show ends
but I don't know if Donna and Harvey
like end up together but if they do it
feels like they needed the two
characters to be on equal levels like
not have this like power Dynamic and
power imbalance they needed them to be
equals if they really were going to be a
successful couple in the long run that's
what I think the reasoning is because it
makes no sense yeah we also forgot to
talk about what started Donna's downfall
which was the Donna the project made by
Benjamin for my spoiler alert by the way
I heard you guys talking about this
fibula I loved having fibola on the toes
oh also you have some competition
because like we don't have a lot of like
straight men on the toast so when we do
like the girlies you know they cream
their pants and of course when you come
on everybody's like oh I love that bed
and what a great husband you know you
get like kind of cool but fibula came
out he's like younger than you and he's
single and like everyone was like
sliding into his DMS being like Oh my
God the fibs so I don't know I'm just
letting you know like you kind of you
got to bring your A-game today all I
know is I'm not here for you trying to
pit me against fibula you're trying to
create drama that doesn't exist and that
said
I don't know if they come on anymore oh
okay no problem Where Are You Gonna
promote guys on Good Guys yeah you guys
is growing okay bye charting bye no I
need this
they really did I was surprised I wasn't
sure you know he was not our typical
demo our typical co-host oh did they
love him yeah I mean he's he's great I
just want to say it was so funny the bar
for co-host is so interesting it's like
when a girl comes on and like if you
know sometimes you just don't Vibe with
the co-host the comments are like like
love you clouds like she was annoying
and like with fibs they were like
obsessed like the bar is so much lower
for the guys they're like wait I need to
marry fibula and like with you they're
like almost done like you didn't even do
anything that's special yeah I'm just
saying like me and fibula are starting a
hate group against the toast because the
way that you just said that the bar is
low for the two of us no the bar is
really [__] high and you get really
high male guests maybe you should get
less shitty females that wasn't a
reflection of your performance or
fabulous you both were excellent fibula
really knocked it out of the park but I
just thought the reception from our
mostly female audience was funny yeah it
is funny yeah it is funny they're funny
they're funny
moving back to the reason I brought the
Donna Connor wood into the equation was
you guys spoke about
uh what the [__] did you guys speak
about I lost my journey statue of
limitations on spoiling a show 10 years
ago watch it or don't yeah people need
to be able to talk about it watch it or
live with the consequences also I highly
recommend watching Suits through season
five and then throwing your TV like off
of your balcony what you had been saying
which I want you to finish your thought
is the Donna the Donna there was this
storyline in suits that was so
unbelievable you had a left field too
honestly I have to imagine that maybe at
that time there was a writer strike must
have been and they've got some like low
budget non-union writers to write this
moronic storyline that wasn't a writer
couldn't be it was a robot no no writer
could have written that storyline it was
human like I felt this I'm watching the
show this it guy goes to Donna and
admits to her that he's been tracking
her and her every move the entire time
she's been at the law firm we've been
logging every one of her decisions to
create like a robot basically like an
Alexa called The Donna so dumb like a
personal assistant tool that actually
does nothing that just has Donna's voice
and then all of a sudden you see her
pitching into VCS she's the secretary
pitching this product that wasn't even
hers and then all of a sudden the
product gets killed and she's so upset
that this is her life's passion but she
didn't even make it and then she become
CEO and Suits is just terrible totally
now that we've actually done our eyes
have been opened actually good
television that said Lewis lit
honestly I should end it up with Fran
Drescher obsessed obsessed
The Nanny and the lawyer I know so it's
just like what we've been up to
oh you better stop One Singular cough
you better stop we've only been going
for 12 minutes one cough for 12 minutes
it's pretty good do you need a water or
something no okay you sure yeah my third
is dry but I'm fine so you feel like
equipped to begin I do to dive in I do
to the Fast Five I do stories I do that
you yes need to know yes period cool and
the best life stories that you need to
know period are brought to you by bowl
and Branch your betting should be the
most important thing in your life I know
for us it is I mean how many hours do we
spend our bed is our sleeping
Arrangement obviously it's our kitchen
it's our office Sanctuary it's our it's
literally a Haven of Peace and
restoration thanks to bowling Branch
start investing in your best sleep with
the softest most luxurious sheets from
Bowling Branch the bowling Branch sheets
feel incredible because they don't cut
any corners and they know that that
takes time to create that kind of
quality each sheet set is slow made for
an unmatched softness with 100 traceable
organic cotton that feels unbelievably
soft for years to come so I know you
like know nothing about the home because
like I do everything but give me
describe your bowl and brand sheets in
three words they're the sheets we've had
our entire time living in this apartment
unbelievable I said three words so
unbelievable unbelievable
soft
cool cool so the sheets that we have are
the signature hem sheets from Bowling
Branch it's their best seller for a
reason they use the highest quality 100
organic cotton threads on Earth each
sheet is slow made for Superior softness
and a better night's sleep they feel
buttery to the touch and are super
breathable so they're perfect for both
cooler and warmer weather like you said
we don't switch them out for the seasons
we just we stay cool we are cool and we
stay cool Ben
made without toxins free from synthetic
pesticides formaldehyde and other harsh
chemicals they give you a 30 night
risk-free guarantee with free shipping
and uh Returns on all U.S orders so get
a better night's sleep with both and
Branch sheets get 15 off your first
order when you use promo code toast at
bowlingbranch.com that's
b-o-l-l-a-n-d branch.com promo code
toast exclusions apply Seaside for
details today's episode is also brought
to you by honey love you know I feel
like you can trust me on on a few things
and when it comes to shapewear I feel
like that is a
topic I feel extremely well versed and
trustworthy on and honey love I love I
discovered honey love before they were a
sponsor from a Facebook ad and I have
worn so many of their products to
weddings events when we speak at
conferences I never leave my house
without some sort of control top without
some sort of shapewear summertime it can
be a really a hard time to suffer in an
uncomfortable bra well thankfully honey
love has revolutionized revolutionized
the bra game upgrade from traditional
bras that use comfortable under
uncomfortable underwire and bulky
Fabrics that trap heat honey loves bras
feature support bonding that eliminates
the need for underwire without
sacrificing a lift they're made with
fabric That's So Soft it's like a second
skin you'll immediately feel them see
the difference it's next level
comfortable you'll forget you're wearing
it for a limited time you can get honey
love on sale get 20 off your entire
order with our exclusive link
honeylove.com Toast of course you'd be
supporting our show and just supporting
your titties so check them out at
honeylove.com forward slash toast
there's nothing worse in the summer than
taking your bra off and seeing like that
line of sweat it's like embarrassing and
gross the Honey Love bras are keeping
your tattoo has cool lifted All Summer
Long
um and that feeling when you like get
home and you just want to rip your bra
off you don't really have that with
honey love because it really feels like
a second skin you can even sleep in it
they've you covered for the everyday
looks workouts wetting and more honey
love is just a brand that I supremely
trust so treat yourself with the best
shapewear on the market and save 20 off
at honeylove.com toast use the exclusive
link for 20 off honeylove.com toast
cinched snatched and lifted it's hot
girl season thanks to Honey love all
right are you ready for our first story
which is kind of I am it was like this
groundbreaking not really expose on
Jimmy Fallon I don't know if you saw
Rolling Stone
came out with this big tell-all former
current staffers speaking to Jimmy's
drinking his behavior on set the toxic
workplace you know it was kind of it was
kind of very standard I feel like the
last one Rolling Stone just did one on
James Corden it was like the Ellen
DeGeneres treatment and uh I feel like
nobody cares that's just like what I'm
seeing and what I'm feeling and I feel
like this was also a very known thing I
feel like
eight years ago somebody told me like
Jimmy Fallon is always drunk and every
time I see him do something whether he's
on a podcast or on his actual show doing
his monologue and appearance I'm like oh
yeah that's a drunk person I feel like
that's just been like a a common secret
that everybody knew and no one was going
to do anything about but Rolling Stone
took matters into their own hand they
launched a full-fledged investigation
um and Jimmy Fallon actually responded
almost immediately and apologized to The
Tonight Show staff after the report
there was like a bunch of stories that
came in about him embarrassing staffers
making them cry apparently like those
celebrity green rooms where celebrities
are held during the regular working
hours they were called like the crying
room like the staffers would go in there
and cry once they were yelled at Jimmy
Fallon just immediately apologized he
did it on an all hands Zoom they had he
said sorry if I embarrassed you your
family your friends I feel so bad I
can't even tell you there was a lot of
um like actual instances that Rolling
Stone
cited specifically and I think he was
responding directly to them this is kind
of like an amazing way of handling it I
just I don't know I feel like he's not
going to get the Ellen James Corden
people hated Ellen they were looking for
a reason to like cancel jump people
hated James Corden for you know whatever
reason it was like the Internet Hate
train people don't hate Jimmy Fallon
would you like to speak oh my God agreed
people don't hate Jimmy Fallon
um if you're apologizing immediately
like you're wrong for that like you're
obviously like you have something to
hide you're in the wrong
um I think like yes it's non-traditional
this isn't like an accounting firm it's
Hollywood so there's always going to be
like a level of crazy but there's really
no excuse for Jimmy himself to be like a
demon
you know like maybe your show Runners we
have an example do we have a singular
example yes there was many examples and
actually you have one it was in the
Rolling Stone article about how um
during a taping with Jerry Seinfeld he
like called out one of the staffers and
like it was like really bad and actually
what's his name what's Jerry Jerry
Seinfeld actually released a statement
before this uh Jimmy Fallon uh apology
and said I was there it didn't really go
down like that like I know what you're
talking about and you're kind of
misconstruing like the situation but the
situation actually did happen Jerry
Seinfeld knew what Rolling Stone was
talking about okay wait here's what
Jimmy Fallon said it's embarrassing and
I feel so bad sorry if I embarrassed you
and your family and your friends I feel
so bad I can't even tell you he added
that he did not intend to quote create
that type of Atmosphere for the show I
want the show to be fun it should be
inclusive to everybody it should be the
best show
the apology comes after two current and
14 former employees claimed that The
Tonight Show has been a toxic workplace
for years this is what they said in the
article nobody told Jimmy no everybody
walked on eggshells especially the shell
Runners you never knew which Jimmy we
were going to get and when he was going
to throw a hissy fit look how many
showrunners went so quickly we know they
didn't last long apparently his show has
had a new showrunner every single year
for every single season which is like
extremely uncommon
sources claimed that Fallon's erratic
Behavior
oh
erratic Behavior led to staff especially
show Runners quitting the company it was
like if Jimmy's in a bad mood everyone's
day is [__] it was very much like
focus on whatever it is that you have to
do because Jimmy's in a bad mood and if
he sees that he might fly off the handle
seven staffers alleged to Rolling Stone
that their mental health was affected by
the negative atmosphere behind the
scenes and that joking about wanting to
kill themselves was common workplace
there there were also allegations that
guest dressing rooms were known as The
Crying rooms for staff this is what one
a former employee said mentally I was in
the lowest place of my life I didn't
want to live anymore I thought about
taking my own life all the time I knew
deep down I would never actually do it
but in my head I'm like why do I think
about this all the time back in 2016
page six actually exclusively reported
that NBC was concerned with Jimmy
Fallon's drinking and that would lead to
problems on the show although the
network denied it at the time following
the publication of that report several
staffers came to his defense he makes a
point of commending you when you do a
great job when he's happy a current
employee who prefer to remain anonymous
told People magazine and any feedback
I've received is always like hey we
don't need to do that again it's been
very constructive and helpful for me and
continuing continuing to put together a
show that he's happy with I've never
been belittled yelled at nothing like
that it's all exactly how a boss should
give feedback to an employee so that was
2016 and it seems like since then
everything has gone completely downhill
because so many people came to his
defense when there were like rumors
about his drinking in 2016 but now in
2023 like not one person chose to go on
the record with their name with rolling
stone former and current employers
everyone's been anonymous
oh is this the time where you want me to
chime in yes
um
this is a very difficult situation yeah
I feel like he now with more information
seems like this is a a bad place to work
I would like to go on the record saying
that you can quit
um right like I mean it's really that's
like an amazing job I get it you're like
a writer a comedian like and you want to
work in this industry like getting a job
there is like that's like the best job
you can get totally
and those people go on to like right for
SNL like it's really like a launching
point I know I just whatever whatever
I'm gonna say is not gonna sound good
okay so like if you want to cut it you
can cut it okay I'm just saying like
people choose to work where they choose
to work they choose to work for either
employees that maybe I mean for
employers that they believe in or they
choose not to work for employers that
they think are are bad people sometimes
it's about like an overall message of a
company or for this it's clearly uh
trying to uh pave the way for a very
promising career but choose if you are
feeling something like suicidal it's
horrendous that's horrendous yeah
you're choosing to work there but I
think he was saying like
I think he was saying like he knew his
feelings were a uh exaggeration like I
don't think he was really feeling
suicidal but like
to be for your job to like make you so
dark but like I also really don't feel
like you should have to give up
something you worked hard for because
somebody has a drinking problem and is
an [__] like it's still it's NBC
you're working at like a company that
has HR but it's like all these benefits
then why can't you ask to work for a
different show at NBC because why should
you have to do that like you worked hard
to get to this The Tonight Show
Jay Leno Johnny Carson it is a legendary
show it is a show that every comedy
writer or TV writer would want to work
on and you got there why the [__] should
you have to give that up because Jimmy
Fallon's a dick and can't control his
liquor okay you know that's fine you
were yeah of course
but if the problem is severe enough you
can also quit of course nobody has to be
anywhere but I also just don't subscribe
to the notion that like you should have
to give up things you've worked for
because life Hollywood isn't fair like
life should be fair I hate that thing
like life should be fair it should it's
not though it's not it's not it's not
Jimmy
we wish you best well he definitely like
has like and if people have been talking
about it since 2016 that's seven years
yeah he's had clearly as a drinking
problem which is very sad and I think
there's been a few
um moments where people were like close
to uncovering it like remember when he
was on the show for like a few months
with like his arm in a crazy sling and
he was like I fell or whatever like I
think there's been a lot of red flags
but it's it's just kind of been this
Open Secret that nobody has addressed
but I think maybe now might be even
though this isn't even like it's a big
story but like it's not gonna affect his
ratings I don't think it's really going
to affect how people perceive him like
he's just kind of this like affable guy
yeah he's very like fever pitch was
great right SNL like he's really like
America's sweetheart for sure for sure
but he comes from like this like history
of
like American like people love him yeah
like I don't think this will affect him
people weren't reasoning for looking for
a reason to hate him like they were with
Ellen and James Corden but it's so
interesting like I I'm surprised that
James Corden was handled the way that he
was like I wouldn't have expected James
Corden to be canceled really I feel like
people just hated him for no reason and
then the article came out and we were
like oh we get it now like people they
were looking for a reason and they got
one people did not like James Corden
because he was like always showing up
with celebrities out of nowhere he was
in like everything it was like he was
literally in the Friends reunion like
what is James Corden doing here like he
became it's that whole thing like I
always quote this but it's true like
likability is a prison like you become
so James Corden overnight carpool
karaoke he was like this British guy
nobody knew about he got this random
show he wasn't even in a good time slot
he was like The Late Late Show it wasn't
supposed to be this big thing and then
everybody loved him and of course what
comes next hate and everybody hated him
hated and he was annoying and it was
James Gordon and then the article came
out and it's like oh now we have an
actual reason to dislike him the same
thing with his uh Balthazar Scandal
where they said he was rude to the
waiter like nobody really was able to
fact check that but they ran with it
because they were looking for a reason
to dislike James Corden I mean no one
was looking for a reason for Jimmy
Fallon and I actually don't think this
will affect him honestly yeah I don't
think his show will be canceled I don't
think he'll go off the air he's in the
most prestigious time slot
in late night on NBC
in Johnny Carson's time like
nobody cares I have one random thought
why
if you take Ellen if you take James if
you take Jimmy if you take any of these
late night folks why are they the ones
who are responsible for working so
closely with everybody at the company
when technically their talent like why
isn't there like a CEO of The Tonight
Show it's called the showrunner oh
that's that person yeah it's like but
like why there seems to be too much
interfacing like if you think about any
other like talent-led project the talent
does not talk to the employees that are
working on the project right but then
but by the way then there will be
another article he thinks he's too good
to talk to produce her totally I'm just
saying if you actually want to solve the
problem yeah you'd think that separating
church and state a bit but it might help
for sure but I think like the best
possible show comes from like Jimmy
being with the writers and then writing
[__] together like in an ideal scenario
it's like a family I get it but I think
a lot of um the toxicity and this
happened with Ellen was like a big part
of her you know that the Expo Jose that
came out about her was about her
showrunner Annie lassner and him and
Ellen were so close like friends family
Vibes so it really starts at the top and
who's at the top Ellen then Andy then
the producer's like it's like a tree I
understand so I hear what you're saying
I actually agree but I think you know if
Jimmy Fallon never spoke to his writers
it's like well that's [__] rude they
write you jokes and now everyone thinks
you're funny and we know you're not
you're writers right see it's a
double-edged sword yes how can you win
like ability is a prison and be a human
being like human beings have problems
human beings are [__] human beings
are sweet like for whatever reason we
choose to like put celebrities on these
pedestals as if they're not just regular
humans with like cool jobs or Cool Jobs
prisons right prisons right but
everybody [__] up and everybody has
these problems but I think these
articles come out like when it's like a
true pattern it's not like Jimmy had a
bad day like of course everybody has a
bad day at work no but no but Jimmy and
again we don't know Jimmy we're just
speculating but it seems like he has a
drinking problem that stinks that's a
personal problem like he should adjust
his drinking yeah and but that's a
personal problem I guess if it affects
the workplace it becomes a work problem
right damn
they're wishing him well wishing
everyone well
um all right are you ready for our next
story am Rihanna and ASAP Rocky have
revealed their unique name for their
second baby so their child's unusual
name has been revealed a month after she
gave birth
uh her and the rapper have named their
son Riot Rose Mayers according to his
birth certificate which was obtained by
the blast on Thursday the name could be
a subtle nod to ASAP asap's track Riot
which was released in July and features
Pharrell it follows the pair uh their
naming tradition favoring the letter R
their first name their first son's name
is Rizza r-z-a and now their second
son's name is riot
it's tough It's not a great name anyone
can make it cool it's ASAP Rocky and
Rihanna's son yeah but
you just never know it's kind of like
getting that tattoo when you're
14 not knowing what it's gonna look like
when you're 90. like if you get a huge
Lion on your back sure it's cool at I
said 14 sure it's cool at 22. right it
won't be cool at 90. now I did really
choose this story obviously I care you
know Rihanna's like a trendsetter I'm
sure everybody's going to be naming
their kids Riot but it made me think you
know because you're a celebrity I am and
we you know God Willie knock on wood
hashembly and her one day we'll have
children
and are we gonna go because you're a
celebrity like and if you are a
celebrity with a child like you have to
name them something crazy God forbid you
name them Rachel you have to name them
Apple yeah
what route are we going to take are we
going to go like
jeans you know I think we should name
our kid like denim yeah
um normal names I feel like you're
wanting to go like really Jewish like
you want your kid's name to be like
Mordecai now I just want I just want
good normal names there's a reason that
there's there's certain names that have
like stood the test of time it's because
they don't mean anything else Ben
doesn't mean anything sure in Hebrew
means Sun but it doesn't mean anything
it's a name it's a name it's a name like
if you want to read into it you can Riot
means causing a a fussle like causing
like a problem like kind of negative
it's negative right it's negative
actually it could be it depends what
kind of Riot we're talking about you
know riots cause change maybe she wants
her son to be a change Baker I
understand
so it also could be negative like riots
you know it's just weird I just don't
think that these kids will end up going
by by like maybe does Blue Ivy go by
Blue yes people call her blue yeah
what's up blue yeah but see now in
hindsight like when when Beyonce said
blue we were like that's crazy now it's
still crazy no it's like her name is
blue you know same with North when Kim
said her baby was named North I was like
honestly are you for real Kim like this
is insane but North is her name they
call her Nori North like but see that's
different I don't think people but they
called no they actually sorry they call
her North 100.
get behind this but like now with time
like it's a name it's crazy how it it's
even like I just don't think it's a name
even Apple
these are not names Gwyneth Paltrow's
daughter like it's a name like it's
crazy how a word
maybe that's what Shakespeare was saying
like what's in a name these are not
names but like they are now no honestly
the fact that you brought up Blue Ivy
like I don't even think of that as a
crazy name anymore okay but when it
happened I was like blue question mark
no I I just you don't agree I I
inherently disagree I will say these are
not names names should be for people and
things like in Judaism we name after
very very important people that have
passed right like to honor them with a
name like do people not honor with names
in some regard like I did think that in
Christianity you name after living
grandparents like there's there's honor
to a name like what honor is blue what
honor is Apple maybe we just don't know
it but there is okay so maybe there's
meaning yeah understood yeah understood
I don't think that there's like I guess
there's meaning to Riot you're right
maybe there's meaning to Riot right we
just don't know it because we're not
Rihanna's family
God I think we should know I think we
should name our child Leaf I think we
should name our child Theo
I agree we should have brought these out
today question this is more for if a
rabbi or a rabbit sin the wife of a
rabbi happens to be listening to today's
episode of the toast can you name after
a living pet I know you can't name after
a living human in Judaism can you name
after a living pet why Theo you actually
want to name our child Leo Theo is an
unbelievable name I agree but like it's
taken no it would honor him it would
honor our true first son while he's
living he's so cute he's an angel I miss
him I know he should have brought him
today when was last time you brought him
now for a while his schedule and mine
like actually conflict
they do lightly conflict in the mornings
we both have a really busy mornings they
do yeah it's true it's true he's at the
U.N okay
are you ready for our next story I am it
is another update in the Joe Jonas
Sophie Turner and honestly I wouldn't
have chosen it but this one is
interesting and as you pointed out this
morning when you read this article it's
quite contradictory so Joe Jonas has
allegedly complained that Sophie Turner
was quote less than supportive after she
gave birth so this is the kind of first
the reason I chose it this is the first
thing that's come out in this very messy
divorce Saga that appears to be in
defense of Sophie so far everything has
been uh Joe's with the kids and she's an
absentee parent and she likes to party
and he likes to be home well now Joe
Jonas was apparently less than
supportive of his now estrained wife
Sophie Turner when she was struggling
after giving birth to their second child
last year according to a new report
sources told TMZ Thursday that the Jonas
Brothers member allegedly pressured
Sophie to attend industry events get out
of the house more despite her not
wanting to be photographed although she
preferred to stay home with their two
daughters Sophie put on a brave face
went to numerous events with her husband
however sorcist told TMZ that Turner has
made it clear that she was uncomfortable
and did not want to be there at a
separate event that Turner did not
attend Joe allegedly complained that his
wife needed to get out more prompting
those around him to suspect that their
marriage had hit a rough patch Jonas's
rep declined to comment on that report
Reps for the estranged couple didn't
immediately return page six request for
comment Joe filed for divorce on Tuesday
after four years of marriage stating in
court documents that their Union was
irretrievably broken in a joint
statement they called it a United
decision
so up until this point everything we've
been hearing is that Sophie likes to
party he wants to be home with the kids
he's the real parent in the relationship
and she's an alcoholic and now it's like
actually she was really struggling
postpartum and didn't want to leave the
house and he kind of forced her to do
that so how can both of these be true
which one is it right there which one is
extremely contradictory extremely
contradictory
and you know we always like to say at
the toast two things can be true at the
same time these actually cannot be they
could be true at different portions of
time perhaps but when they met Sophie's
27 yeah yeah he's 34. like she's younger
if she did want a party that's fine yeah
she's in her party era right right like
27 I get that she chose to have kids but
still good for her it does now seem
though like she did not want to party
right and this article is quite negative
towards Joe and I certainly hope it's
not true pressuring your wife he's part
of life to leave the house postpartum
everybody knows that a postpartum woman
you nobody knows what a postpartum woman
is dealing with no but then also on the
taking it to another level being famous
like when you go to it's not like I'm
going to my husband's holiday work party
like you're going to an event where
pictures of you are going to be blasted
all over the world before you wake up
the next morning that element of being
postpartum is even more harrowing like
your physical appearance you're feeling
so emotional so hard hormonal your
body's change like no wonder she doesn't
want to leave the house yeah and it also
I don't know there was a period of time
over the last year where I could not
check Tick Tock and not see the Jonas
Brothers yeah no on somebody's something
like they have been like again again
just like right when Sophie's have like
giving birth having kids how old is
their child uh she gave her birth like
to her last kid like six months ago okay
so it's fairly new Fresh So from the
entire time that she was pregnant and up
until like very recently they have been
everywhere everywhere over time
promoting doing the most being as front
like facing the camera is humanly
possible trying to make sure that their
album or their tour or whatever the hell
is going on is front and center and I'm
sure some publicist was like we need you
and Sophie to be more present because so
much a part of their brand is like the
Jonas Brothers and then the Jonas
sisters Priyanka Chopra Danielle Jonas
Sophie Turner it's like this click
that's actually been really good for for
their brand everybody like is obsessed
with the wives yeah so Sophie wanting to
take time for herself I guess if you're
like a narcissist you could see that as
like attack on the Jonas Brothers but
like everybody needs to calm down
totally and like seriously leave her
alone but this is the reason I chose
this story is because it shows like a
sign of life from Sophie it seems like
the last week has been just like blow
after blow to Sophie and she hasn't
defended herself her publicist has not
her team her Camp has not put anything
out about her as a mother and this is
like the first time it's like thank you
thank you yeah and being six months
postpartum with a six-month-old infant
like this is literally and another child
this is the last [__] thing they need
no or she needs she needs especially if
her husband's on tour oh right like she
like I don't understand The Narrative of
how is it possible that he is the parent
in the relationship when he is on tour
on a world tour right is that six month
old baby on tour that's what they're
making it seem like oh that that baby is
on the bus that well not the bus but no
but that he's on tour and the kids are
with him got it and where's she
that's what they're alleging like that's
what's been said got it it's like wear a
sofa I'm like digging deep in the weeds
but like is she breastfeeding I don't
know I'm just saying how could you be
without but by the way maybe she's not
the last show in Boston I think it was
she was there with the kids
so it's all this is like so crazy messy
and I don't know if we'll really ever
find out like what the truth is but I
think the truth is that it's none of our
business
couldn't agree more yeah like this is a
family yeah leave them alone okay but
like we just like made it our business
because we spoke about it no I know
Choice okay yeah none of our business
wishing them well
um our next story is brought to you by
game time which is very appropriately
because we're gonna be talking about the
US Open and you actually can get tickets
to the US Open on game time buying
tickets to your favorite events should
not be stressful game time is the fast
and easy way to buy tickets for all the
sports music comedy and theater near you
with killer deals on last minute tickets
and their best price guaranteed you can
stop stressing over tickets and start
getting hyped for the fun you're gonna
have so game time is the place for last
minute ticket deals forget planning
months in advance game time has deals on
tickets right up to the day of the event
get exclusive Flash Deals on tickets for
football basketball baseball concerts
comedy theater and more the game time
guarantee means you'll always get the
best price if you find tickets in the
same section and row for Less game time
will credit you 110 of the difference
it's the fastest growing ticket
ticketing app in the country for a
reason get images of your seats before
you buy you'll know exactly what to
expect when you arrive buy tickets in a
matter of seconds it's just two Taps and
you're all set tickets are then sent
directly to your phone so you never have
to dig through your email snag the
tickets without the stress with game
time I I actually uh they had amazing
tickets for the US Open day of on game
time I checked when we were going
download the game time app create an
account and use code toast for 20 off
your first purchase that's uh code toast
for the game time app terms apply again
create an account redeem with code toast
for that 20 off download game time today
last minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed
thank you game time sir answering
today's episode yes all right so in that
Spirit our story uh number four is about
the climate protester who glued his feet
to the floor at the US Open interrupting
Coco golf's semi-final win over muchova
so I was watching this last night I
don't need to read the article I lived
it there was like a pause in in the game
and it was like there was a disruptance
in the 200 level and then like it
literally
kept going on they were off the court
for 30 minutes excuse me
and a lot of people they were everybody
started chanting get him out get him out
and the people on TV didn't know what
was going on because it was all the way
up they couldn't see
um and then things started coming out on
social media people were videoing like
three people had stood up and started
chanting something about fossil fuels
and NYPD and Arthur Ash security came
and removed them so why did it take 30
minutes because the third guy wouldn't
leave he glued his bare feet to the
cement floor of Arthur Ashe Stadium and
it took 30 minutes to get him unglued
nuts and escorted out like the players
actually didn't even sit on the court
they went back inside and like you know
were in the gym like staying hot or
whatever
I know that you said that you're not
reading the article do you want me to no
just the part about Coco goth saying oh
yes you're actually right like just read
that part so during uh the press
conference after the
match which she did end up winning
um muchova the girl who lost said I
thought it was like fans screaming and
cheering but it was a group called
extension extension Extinction Rebellion
that was responsible for the protest but
Coco Goff actually uh
spoke kind of in defense of them let me
find exactly what she said
throughout history moments like this are
definitely defining moments I believe
you know in climate change I don't
really know exactly what they were
protesting I know it was about the
environment I 100 believe in that I
think there are things that we can do
better would I prefer it not happening
in my match 100 yeah I'm not going to
sit here and lie so she supports the
message not the delivery so then maybe
it was michova who said that like
somebody in that article said that they
were down for what happened
this is what Coco said
we didn't know how long it was going to
take we were talking to the supervisor
at security and you know they said it
would be as quick as five minutes or as
long as an hour it was tough trying to
figure out if we should stay warm or
conserve energy muchova said I just
wanted to get off the court and then
keep myself a little warmed up and not
just stand there
that's all really yeah I thought I've
read something else and machova said we
see it here and there on some occasions
not just with tennis it is what it is
what can we do about it they both were
like very passe about it they didn't
want to you know I don't know what
article I read okay so they're gonna
come out and be like you know Coco golf
doesn't stand for environmentalism but
also it's [__] annoying disrupting
like a public
event an outing is never going to be a
good way to get your message across
because honestly everyone who was there
and everyone who was watching was
annoyed at the delay and honestly now I
think environmentalists are [__]
annoying so maybe it had an adverse
effect unfortunately but I guess like
we're talking about we're talking about
it we're talking about it so it had the
effect that they wanted really good I
would like by the way but but did it
because nobody not even Coco nobody knew
what they were actually protesting like
what about there's a lot of things going
on in the environment and I just want to
say that whole thing like now we're
talking about it environmental issues
don't have a PR problem I feel like
we're always talking about the
environment yeah so it's true like okay
now we're talking about it again now
what now what we're always talking about
right Leonardo DiCaprio all the celebs
love to talk about it and they get on
their private planes and like destroy
the environment it isn't now what right
no it's not it's not a uh uh there's
there isn't an awareness problem
an issue that has an awareness problem
yeah 100 we are aware now what it's like
probably the biggest we're aware that
he's talking about it we're where now
what right now what I want to see the
bottom of that guy's feet I know like
glued himself to what did he use to glue
himself
was it couldn't have been Elmer's
because Elmer's would not have stuck
into the ground no we all used to put
Elmer's on our hands it doesn't do any
school and it peels off a glue gun too
hot also where do you plug it in no
electricity you can't so that leaves
Gorilla Glue and that would leave his
feet in a credibly compromised position
really bad also he's really [__]
lucky this [__] and I'm calling him a
[__] because he glued his feet don't
you explain
he's really lucky that the police didn't
just pick him up and rip his feet from
the ground that they believed him by the
way maybe it's all a farce maybe he
claimed that they were glued very true
right so they wouldn't you're right NYPD
could have just like grabbed him and
pulled him and yanked this is this is a
nice story for the NYPD they were very
nice to this protester no who's being
like recently removing his feet from
lightly removing his feet from the
ground do you remember that woman who
accidentally used Gorilla Glue to set
her hair no oh yes I do and she had to
undergo like crazy surgery there was
like not many times we wanted to do it
honestly Gorilla Glue should be outlawed
no or you should need like a driver's
license or something to purchase it the
fact that you can walk into like a CVS
it's true and buy [__] Gorilla Glue
but when I go into CVS or it's Wayne
Reed I need to a behind lock and key is
my deodorant because people I can't get
a deodorant without a key but I can buy
Gorilla Glue and seal my eyelid shut and
then all of a sudden like one of my
cousins can pick it up and put it on
their armpit and rip off all their
armpit air but I need to go behind
locking Keepers it doesn't do that no
I'm just saying like it's an amazing
point right it's dangerous like how hard
is it to pick up anything no it's true
like in New York City everything over
five dollars is behind lock and key like
my razors for my leg behind lock and key
deodorant that's not like the shittiest
brand behind lock and key everything is
Zyrtec Advil if you want the liquid gels
behind lock and key if you want the [__]
Walgreens ibuprofen brand oh you can get
that no problem yeah I admitted this on
Good Guys yesterday what I will go into
Dwayne Reed and instead of calling for
somebody to come with the lock and key I
will literally break my hand reaching it
behind the plastic and pull out whatever
I can get yeah because I'm not waiting
for somebody to come and unlock my
deodorant it's also so personal when I
go to a pharmacy like maybe I'm buying
tampons maybe I'm buying condoms maybe
people are buying pregnancy tests
condoms you know what I mean it's
personal to have to call someone over
like hi can I get these jumbo Magnum
Trojans like it's true it's embarrassing
it's true but regardless nothing should
be high lock and key agreed have better
security in the store or shut down the
store entirely if you can't handle
people walking into your store and not
stealing up no a bottle of Gillette
crime is such a problem like these
pharmacies they're not doing this by
choice it hinders their sales because I
walk in I'm like you know what you say
that and we're talking about it as if it
was crime but then all of a sudden we're
talking about the fact that their
generic brand is not behind lock and key
so is it for crime or is it so that it's
more difficult to buy Advil so you're
just gonna buy the IB Program brand
where they make it significantly higher
margin on are they pretending that it's
crime when in reality it's the crime of
the store it's the crime of the store I
agree but contrary to what I just said
they don't have a Walgreens brand
deodorant that I can just pick up and
they don't have a Walgreens brand super
glue which is what you were initially
talking about yeah Gorilla Glue terrible
you're right it's kind of like a crazy
product that's like weird same product
you don't have to be like 18 to buy it
no and it's it's it's terrible but like
not terrible but when you need it like
for you know household things like you
broke a boss or something like it really
works for sure it works especially an
amazing person which is dangerous agreed
are you ready for open the final story
that's kind of a convergence of your
world and mine sure Kim Kardashian is
slammed for a tone deaf tribute to Steve
Harwell in a gold bikini so Kim
Kardashian appeared to pay tribute to
the late Smash Mouth singer Steve
Harwell with a signature snap of herself
in a bikini but not everyone was feeling
the love she posted a mirror selfie to
Instagram Wednesday where she was
wearing a metallic two-piece and her
caption was All That Glitters Is go
world that's what she captioned in
reference to the band's hit song
All-Star now people were quick to
comment Loki tone deaf but go off Kim
there's literally people that are dying
literally someone dies and you use their
lyrics to post a thirst trap eye roll
Emoji others pondered whether Kardashian
was even aware that the rocker had
passed away on Monday now I think it's
worth mentioning that you know Steve
Harwell a great Lyricist he did not
invent All That Glitters as gold he used
that very common phrase
in a lyric
that's a that's a phrase outside of the
song
are you okay no like this is so [__]
dumb yeah okay like
Kim Kardashian was was paying tribute it
sounds like she wasn't no I don't agree
okay no I don't agree that it was a
complete coincidence she was wearing a
gold bikini and so when you wear gold
and you take a picture and you post it
on Instagram you always want to have
like a funny quirky caption so she was
like okay Gold All That Glitters Is Gold
okay so you can play that angle I in
reality am going to play the angle that
she was signaling some kind of race
tribute and I want to say that the
tribute was incredibly nice thoughtful
there is no reason why any kind like
she's not using like again and I'm a a
big Smash Mouth like this I love this
this you're really feeling the loss of
Steve Harwell you're a big Smash Mouth
guy no so I was I was gonna say he
really wasn't like he wasn't that famous
right he was famous but like the idea
that his one or two of his songs are
like deeply embedded in pop culture but
he himself as a celebrity he's not it's
not it's not and so the idea that Kim
Kardashian is somehow using it to prop
herself up he's brain dead like it
doesn't make any sense if anything she
is actually bringing more light to his
very sad and tragic death
by posting this it's an amazing take
it's terrible I just want to say you've
kind of been like this episode like
really giving fire takes yeah well it's
because I read the story so yeah you
never do I was able to prepare you did
you you usually just like throw him in
front of me and I'm like what happened
here no I actually read them and uh
yeah Smash Mouth
uh Steve Harwell it's very sad it is I
don't think we know more details than
what I read earlier but such a terrible
drinking problem alcoholism died of just
a liver problem from the Jimmy Fallon
stuff to this just like if if you have a
problem with drinking like fix it if
someone tried their lives it's not that
easy no no go to go to find help that's
what I mean but if somebody in your life
I think a better kind of PSA for this
episode if someone in your life is
struggling you know be there for them
because it really it has such terrible
consequences yes yes alcoholism it's a
deadly disease and you know what a lot
of times it's hereditary it can run in
your family so like you're literally
left with no choice it's terrible it's
horrible it's terrible
um and on the Steve Harwell stuff if
anybody somehow has not seen the movie
Rat Race you gotta see is he in it no
but I mean he's in it Smash Mouth
performs at the end like there's this
big concert what songs are they saying
uh they sing All-Star now do they have
other songs
yeah I they do the cover of I'm a
Believer oh when I saw her face okay but
no that's not their song like obviously
we all know them from Shrek uh Hey Now
You're an art that's a Shrek right and
that was also just like but I'm saying
everybody says that it's from Shrek it's
from Rat Race okay their top five songs
are of course Ulster I'm a Believer and
then walking on the sun 150 streams
okay
but like
watch Rat Race that's kind of did I say
more is that what you want to leave the
people with today just read quickly just
read the castle Rat Race I don't have my
phone it's important okay it's important
do you know that I've never seen Rat
Race you're lying yeah I don't even know
what it like what I'm actually I'm like
disgusted is is it Jackie Chan no uh
what am I thinking of the Jackie Chan
that you love Rush Hour rush hour yeah
Rush Hour doesn't even literally I said
hold the candle twice and I don't even
know if it's the right expression okay
it doesn't even come close to Rat Race
okay Rat Race cast uh read this cast
listen to this Rowan Atkinson yes Mr
Bean John Cleese yes Vince vuluff I've
never heard of any of these people oh
wow I can't believe you would recommend
a movie that has Cuba Gooding Jr in it
by the way he was fantastic keep going
wow Whoopi Goldberg
breckenmeyer Ben this is like not an
impression Seth Green yes it is Seth
Green John Lovitz John Lovitz oh Ben you
didn't say Kathy najimi was in the movie
no had you said Queen Kathy do you know
I'd walk do you know yeah and do you
know who she's married to in the movie
who John movitz do you know who Kathy
najimi is of course I I would take a
bullet for Kathy no I take a bullet for
their marriage there's an unbelievable
scene they're a lovely Jewish Family in
the movie oh wow and they end up with
the premise of the movie the premise of
the movie is that are there any rocks in
it no that there is a race uh they're at
a casino and all of these high rollers
are looking for a another way to get on
get in on the actions they orchestrate
this race of human beings it's like an
amazing race where they all bet on these
people to go across the country and like
get this key that has that unlocks this
box at the end and you're like tracking
their journey and they're all trying to
race towards the money it's a race for
money it literally sounds moronic okay
it's literally unbelievable and on uh
John lovitz's Journey there are 9 Jewish
Family they accidentally have a run-in
uh with with Adolf Hitler's supporters
oh God and uh they end up driving Adolf
Hitler's car and it's it's the best wait
does the movie take place in the 40s no
no I don't understand you got to watch
it everybody watch Rat Race that's what
you want the people to know you want
them to listen to your podcast buy
Spritz
Listen to Good Guys
check out Sports society and check out
specifically pink lemonade notify for
details so that you know when it's gonna
sell out it's sold out last time three
days everybody's like where'd it go it's
gone and it'll be gone again so notify
watch Rat Race if you have trouble
drinking with drinking seek help and if
you see somebody that has a drinking
problem in your life help them help them
so that's like the message you want to
leave people with it is those four
things like those four things and
um services are gonna be so confused why
rat race all of a sudden shot up it's
like yep by the way it's not going to
because you like didn't really like make
it seem enticing I have literally no
interest in watching it after the
description it's the best movie I can't
explain why but it is just trust me okay
will you watch it no why not like maybe
maybe in like a year no yes
yeah all right that's our show thank you
guys so much hope you guys enjoyed toast
week uh returns next week we're back and
we've got five episodes next yes we have
five episodes next week and I'm gonna be
in Florida for the Jewish holiday so
I'll be in studio with Jackie which will
be fabulous so you have that to look
forward to thank you so much for
listening to the test online Morning
Show where we deliver the fast five
stories you need to remember the Friday
and YouTube so for watching this on
YouTube please don't forget to subscribe
subscribe
talented we are have an amazing day
thank you Ben for being here thank you
and have a great weekend guys love you
bye guys